biotronik a pris l'eau aujourd'hui cette
drogue dure à gharios j'ai envie de
faire une belle vidéo sur ce jeu parce
que ça m'a manqué ouais c'est manière un
peu nul de justifier moutons bonjour
bouton home et quels débuts autres
j'avais pleuré j'ai à la fois jamais
fait un aussi bon début diémé jamais
ainsi pourri quoi les semoirs amont la
an plus tôt et puis arrête tu ramon la
ram ont enfin tu as raté un monde mais
tu fais quoi toi là ce marché 23 à
casteau à elle les fous ok j'ai parlé il
m'a coupé la parole ou à la belle poule
et john boye jean phi thai dans le sanwi
joueurs je te manger je m'appelle le cas
on a même nom c'est un signe je pense
qu'il faut que tu puisses te manger non
t'as pas le choix
à part ça tu est dite et redite tu est
atteint d'une tendinite ou de bêtes en
bulle en bulle bull head blue bulls
je peux être bon je bous bull voilà ne
buvez pas de coca ça ça fait que vous
fait bouffer dans ya le petit squeak a
pris 1 deviendra grand et en plus y'a
j'ai les crocs devant moi je m'en fous
je bouffe oh oh oh oh oh why am celui-là
à coco bellouz merci la gratuité de lac
au but qui vaut alors mais c'est notre
collègue elle te plaît désolé mais j'ai
besoin de toi pour buter à l'eau alors
je dois faire c'est que tu es vautours
des noirs vient la viande est bien là
encore des lotions en tant que mots
bâlois perfect c'était presque parfait
holzbau frisé banon n'est pas assez gros
au père fait qu il la fit pour tim
manche gros fdp perfect regarder il sait
que mais non mais ces [ __ ] la [ __ ]
le couple aux nazis convient de se taper
[ __ ] jet du bouchon à leur tour pour
trouver un contentement
on n'a jamais vu ça en 28 vidéo dagar
you tu sais ce qui t'attend perfect
regarde pas comme ça sa part trop loin
j'aime les fesses non mes maigres
premier qui s'appelle aux belges
beaucoup trop gros quoi cet homme
étaient immangeables
l'abbé triste de cette masse appelé
j'aime les fesses elle ne fait rien lr
avec peu de courage sur cette feuille
petits carreaux mais n'arrive jamais à
manger qui que ce soit ah j'avais oublié
que j'avais une deuxième partie [ __ ]
au ces cette occasion que je rêve
d'avoir gelé jamais bande de pervers je
parlais des bides des sondés
instrumental quoi nous devons grandir
repartir de zéro wister leur forme ne
put un homme est maigre mais arrête
j'en ai marre là jessica hay locke et
aurillac tient elle m'a brisé le coeur
en nombre regardez fx de pro et jesse
des bars tu mettras part à toi tu as
fais l'amour dies oh la vache premier
rencard premier bisou alors là ça se
fête
on fait péter le jeu non je pu toucher à
cette bouteille tout à l'heure ça elle
m'a tuer combat combat combat voilà
voilà
il le vide pour pour [ __ ] mais ça
m'énerve mais ça m'énerve c'est quoi vos
délires l' affaire des complots naze et
[ __ ] [ __ ] mais retourne au 3ème
round le but le troisième reich à la
conquête du monde riait ça c'est une
vidéo sur itunes fait par les mecs qui
me viennent de move est là avec leurs
complots de merde et rsa c'est le mec
qui m'a bouffé mais ça c'est leur
vaisseau ils sont tous en train de jouer
à ya eu là dedans si on avance un peu
effectivement on peut voir des des
hordes de fans pour aller les rejoindre
pour joaillier a eu avec eux ah bah
voilà ça c'est ce qui se passe dans leur
caleçon quand ils bouffent quelqu'un
comme moi par exemple il faut que je me
détende il faut que je me détourne il
veut que je mène la musique hawaï à
l'élevage mais c'est là j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] c'est parti enjouaillez alors à
tous et défoncé
[Musique]
là
dans l'ohio
oh là bas âge
[Musique]
ouais au tas j'aime pas j'aime pas la
musique ah ouais j'aime pas ça on avait
dû du métal bordel voilà ça s'amuser
k-way
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ben c'est quoi
de plus j'ai contacté k way la chance ne
sourit jamais dit que le kawaï me
porterait chance mais qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait mettre que musique plus tard on
court après la victoire voilà où j'avais
entendu parler de cet homme depuis 2004
venez on les mange tous un par un en a
un on les fronts sont les boues et on
leur fait des gros toi ok nickel vient
dit que ça dégage
allez là c'est notre dernière tentative
de la soie non mais faut pas plus au
fait pourquoi tu pleures tient qu'à mon
grand tu veux manger ou pas aller lui
c'est votre poulain tiens prends super
sasso j'ai créé une alliance on va voir
média 6 bars ses patrons une alliance
mais on a des stocks il est venu manger
alors qu on la nourrit d'elle mais
qu'attendez est dès que j'ai recommencé
voilà tu vas il va il va société va nous
manger
[Musique]
laissez-moi apporter cette souffrance
dans mon coeur en silence bas [ __ ] et
dire qu'on en est la cause de tous ces
complots nazis de merde l'art toujours
ce n'est plus gêné un tribun en france
c'est mon pays c'est le mien j'adore la
france ô
[Musique]
france pourquoi m'as tu fais ça je paie
mes impôts comme tout le monde on pas
s'ils vont payer pour les ai pas c'est
pourquoi tu m'as fait safran à cotonou
pac voyage ans d'aventuré c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas l'aimer comme d'habitude
ça m'a fait plaisir d'y revenir mine de
rien n'est pas trop c'est une pratique
veut rien dire ben écoute et on l étude
je veux pas vous mentir je vous souhaite
de bien vous portez voilà de bien porter
votre sac aussi pour un encours de main
leur envie de me tuer c'est normal
encore merci à vous regarder et la santé
au travail dans une prochaine vidéo 4e
ronde pis
[Musique]